on her days off Paloma hon Onan loves
heading into the woods the environmental
activist is glad that 2/3 of her native
Finland is covered in forests although
most of it our commercial forests and
not wild ones like in this National Park
near Helsinki forestry forests would be
pre harvested for the trees to go faster
bigger and they would be like
fertilizers might be used for to create
more growth in a shorter period of time
Finland's lumber industry it seems is
out to harvest and process more trees
than ever last year a record number of
trees were cut down to make wood and
paper products but environmentalists
like Paloma hon Onan are sounding the
alarm at the moment where we're burning
our forests and we're using them for the
short short lasting products and also
the young forests they don't absorb
carbon as efficiently asked a little bit
older ones
Finland's forests play a key role as co2
sinks after all global warming is having
a very strong effect especially on
northern Europe the country's
center-left government has therefore
decided that Finland's lumber industry
must change it wants to make the country
carbon neutral by 2035 but mass logging
certainly won't help achieve this goal
in Finland have majority of the first is
privately owned so we will have to find
incentives for forest owners to to grow
their forests older perhaps harvest more
selectively older so those specific
tools and policy or financial incentives
need to be developed but the the
direction of travel is clear and that's
also clear to the to the industry but
the country's timber industry which
forms the backbone of Finland's economy
wants to keep operating as before after
all one out of five finish
Goods is made of wood an industry
representatives say they're looking into
making sustainable products like
textiles from cellulose fibres you need
to use the wood otherwise it becomes
again an emitter of co2 so if you want
to be part of the solution using trees
as a way of capture of co2 you then at a
later stage you need to also use the
wood and plant new trees that's the way
have you keep it as I think for for many
decades but Paloma hon Onan doesn't buy
this argument
she says logging always harms the
environment the numbers of threatened
species for example in forests is
growing so and the carbon things are
decreasing so obviously we're not doing
enough so people are now starting to see
what what does it mean on the ground
level to increase the logging so the
clear cuts are are in people's backyards
they are they are they're affecting the
waters that people use they are
affecting forests that people use for
picking parries and mushrooms and
they're for recreational purposes so in
the local level people are waking up now
and resisting big investments and
clearcuts Finland is still largely
covered in forest but Paloma hon Onan is
very worried that it still won't be
enough to weaken the effects of climate
change